c'est où tout le monde les résultats du
vote de la quatrième série de scènes
soir à deux sont tombés hier donc je
propose de découvrir ensemble voilà ça
donne ça c'est l'intelligence
artificielle et le machine learning
gagner vous avez été 6494 à voter merci
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup de votes et en
a pas mal qui s'attendaient à ce
résultat mais en fait ce résultat il a
absolument rien de très évidente puisque
en fait les résultats sont
incroyablement serré je vous ai montré
les résultats ça et en gros ça se loue
finalement assez peu de choses
vous voyez qu'il ya aucun duel dans
lequel il ya plus de soixante et enfin
61 39 entre lia et les stades c'est le
plus gros écart mais finalement ça se
joue assez peu de choses et surtout si
vous regardez entre parlant que l'ia et
le chaos ou entre l'ira et la lgo ça
s'est joué vraiment très peu de choses
si l'ia ko we are going il ya probable
et switcher où il ya nombre d'un porte
clé qu'elle avait switcher sera changé
le vainqueur de converser dans nos rues
ainsi que marcel et du coup il y aurait
eu forcément un tirage au sort et les
ans un peu une priorité de 1 que l'ia
soit élu là il y as et vainqueur de
confort c'est bien pour ceux qui aiment
pas les tirages au sort moi j'espère un
tirage au sort donc pas déçu mais c'est
pas grave affaire avec l'ia mais autres
remarques à faire qui est assez amusante
c'est qu' il n'y a quasiment pas de
cycle de comptoir ça y est un seul cycle
de condorcet c'est tout en bas entre
l'algèbre les espaces et et les stats
mais sinon on a un ordre total ce qui
est super surprendre parce qu'a priori
il n'y a pas vraiment de structure tout
cas c'est pas du tout une structure
unidimensionnel donc je rappelle qu'à
remonter aurait donc thibault c'est une
seule fille avait parlé un petit peu de
ça ne l'est pas dit explicitement de
l'hameçon unis dimensionnalité mais
pourquoi est-ce que lorsqu'il ya une
seule dimension bas il ya souvent un
vainqueur de combourg celle là il n'y a
pas de dimension a priori on pourrait
croire notre pure mata mata piqué ou
mathématiques informatique en fait ça ça
devrait pas trop avoir des votes pascal
patron jim est en tout cas il ya ça me
semble être une des options des plus
informatiques ou les plus appliqués et
célia kelly du tout la solution
centriste la solution centriste et
antiques et vous voyez que malgré ça
malgré l'absence de structures dans
l'ensemble des candidats bat finalement
on a une structure m'a quasiment un
ordre total sur l'ensemble des
alternatives ça suggère que même dans
des élections où il n'y a pas de
structure unique héros national il y
aura souvent un cadeau de noces est un
sacré argument en faveur de
l'utilisation du scrutin ont commencé en
2000 et si lé vainqueur de condorcet il
faut les élire et le scrutin de
condorcet randomisée et une bonne façon
de se faire
voilà donc ce sera là il ya eu
l'intelligence artificielle la prochaine
série super cool ça lorsque c'est
l'option qui est peut-être la plus
proche de trucs non mathématiques on va
parler notamment vers est invité au
niveau messieurs fille pour parler un
petit peu de caisse que l'intelligence
est là mais il y aura aussi des trucs
bien moteur
on parlait de théorème du pack learning
est un genre qui sont des trucs bien
noté e puis aussi les réseaux de
neurones arrêter des centres de crédit
en a parlé
l'apprentissage de superviser non
supervisées comment est ce qu'on
construit une morale pour augmenter dans
un télésiège
bref plein de sujets vraiment vraiment
cool